You know how there are certain stories that, in your family or your circle of friends, become infamous, favorite stories that people tell? Well, for a generation of people working in public radio, especially documentary producers, the story of how Scott Carrier got on the radio is one of those stories. Here's what happened.
你知道有些故事在你的家庭或朋友圈里，会成为家喻户晓、备受推崇的经典故事吗？对于一代公共广播工作者，尤其是纪录片制作人来说，斯科特·卡里尔（Scott Carrier）如何进入广播界的故事就是其中之一。事情是这样的。
Scott was living in Salt Lake City and things weren't going so great. His marriage was coming apart. He had a job painting a semi-conductor factory that was easy to walk away from. But from time to time, when he was listening to an especially great story on the radio, on public radio, he would think to himself, I could do that. And so one day he got himself a tape recorder and walked to the highway and stuck out his thumb and headed east to the headquarters of NPR News in Washington DC. And anybody who picked him up and gave him a ride, he interviewed. So after a couple weeks on the road, he arrives at NPR's old offices on M Street in Washington with all these interviews in his backpack.
斯科特当时住在盐湖城，生活并不顺心。他的婚姻正在破裂。他当时有一份粉刷半导体工厂的工作，但他随时都能辞职走人。但每当他在公共广播电台听到特别棒的故事时，他就会想：我也能做到。于是有一天，他弄到一台录音机，走到高速公路上，伸出大拇指搭车，一路向东前往位于华盛顿特区的全国公共广播电台（NPR）新闻总部。一路上，但凡载他一程的人，他都会进行采访。就这样在路上走了几周后，他背着装满采访录音的背包，抵达了位于华盛顿M街的NPR旧办公室。
It was a Sunday. The place was mostly deserted. Only the staff of weekend All Things Considered and some engineering staff were there in the building. But there was a telephone in the lobby of that building and Scott called in, and the then-host of weekend All Things Considered , Alex Chadwick, happened to be the one who picked up the phone. And Scott explained that he had just arrived, having hitchhiked across the country, and now he had all these tapes, and he would like it if somebody would show him how to turn the tapes into a radio story. Which, incredibly, somebody did.
那是个周日。办公室里空荡荡的，只有周末版《万事皆如此》（All Things Considered）的制作人员和一些工程技术人员在楼里。不过大厅里有一部电话，斯科特打了过去，正好是当时《万事皆如此》周末版的主持人亚历克斯·查德威克（Alex Chadwick）接的电话。斯科特解释说他刚搭便车横跨全国来到这里，现在他带了这么多录音带，希望能有人教他如何把这些带子剪辑成一个广播故事。令人难以置信的是，真的有人教了他。
Most people on the radio sound like each other, the same way that most people on TV sound like other people on TV, and most writing in the newspaper is like all the other writing in the newspaper. Scott sounds only like himself. There's a feeling in his stories that's unlike anything anybody else does.
大多数广播电台的声音听起来都大同小异，就像大多数电视节目听起来都像其他电视节目，大多数报纸上的文章也像其他报纸上的文章一样。斯科特的声音听起来只像他自己。他的故事里有一种不同于任何人的独特情感。
And so, today, we're going to do something different. We're going to be bringing you an entire hour of stories from one contributor, from Scott Carrier. We wanted to try this, and try it with Scott, because there's just something in this set of stories where, when you put them all together, somehow they seem to be telling one long story in a really nice way.
所以今天，我们要尝试一些不同的做法。我们将为你带来整整一小时由同一位贡献者——斯科特·卡里尔——讲述的故事。我们想尝试这种形式，并选择斯科特，因为这组故事中有一种特别的东西，当你把它们放在一起时，它们似乎以一种非常美妙的方式讲述了一个漫长的故事。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, stories by one of the most interesting people working in radio, Scott Carrier. Our show today in four acts, including, in Act Three, Scott Carrier heads out on a mission to discover whether amnesia-- the kind that's in the movies where someone gets bonked on the head and you can't remember anything-- he tries to find out whether that actually happens in real life.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天的节目将播出广播界最有趣的人之一，斯科特·卡里尔的故事。今天的节目分为四个部分，其中在第三部分，斯科特·卡里尔将踏上一段寻找之旅，去探究电影中那种“被人敲了头就会丧失所有记忆”的失忆症，在现实生活中是否真的存在。
Our show today in four acts. Stay with us.
今天的节目分为四个部分，请继续收听。
Act One, The Test. A couple years back, Scott Carrier was hired to interview men and women in Utah who were diagnosed with schizophrenia. He got the job because the director of the research project heard some of his radio stories and thought that he was a good interviewer, somebody who knew how to listen. So they taught Scott to administer this test that measured mental health. It was 100 questions, each of which was scored on a scale of one to seven. It took an hour to give the test. Scott was paid $30 for each test he gave. The people he gave the test to got $5.
第一部分：测试。几年前，斯科特·卡里尔受聘去采访犹他州被诊断为精神分裂症的男女。他得到这份工作是因为研究项目的负责人听过他的一些广播故事，觉得他是一位很好的采访者，是个懂得如何倾听的人。于是他们教斯科特进行这项测量心理健康的测试。测试共有100个问题，每个问题按一到七分进行评分。完成一次测试需要一个小时。斯科特每做一次测试能得到30美元，而接受测试的人能得到5美元。
I was hired to interview men and women in the state of Utah who receive Medicaid support for treatment of mental illnesses generally diagnosed as schizophrenia. I had little understanding of schizophrenia before I began, and I have little more understanding now. I took the job because I had no other. I took the job because I'd just quit my steady job, my professional job, after realizing that what I wanted more than anything was to put my boss on the floor and stand on his throat and watch him gag. Then my wife moved out, took the kids and everything. She said, I've thought about it and I really think it's the best thing for me at this time in my life.
我受聘去采访犹他州那些领取医疗补助以治疗通常被诊断为精神分裂症的精神疾病患者。在开始这项工作之前，我对精神分裂症知之甚少，现在依然了解不多。我接受这份工作是因为我没有别的选择。我接受这份工作是因为我刚辞掉了那份稳定的职业工作，当时我意识到，我最想做的事情就是把我的老板按在地板上，踩住他的喉咙，看着他窒息。然后我妻子搬走了，带走了孩子和家里的一切。她说：“我考虑过了，我真的认为这对我目前的人生阶段来说是最好的选择。”
And so I took the job interviewing schizophrenics because it was offered to me and because it was all there seemed to be. And it seemed somehow predestined, a karmic response that could not be avoided. It would only be temporary, something to get through the summer, and I was told that they needed someone willing to drive around the state, through the small towns, searching out individuals who were often transient and prone to hiding. I like to drive, I like to travel, and I like the idea of pursuit, so I took the job and did the job, and my life will never be the same.
于是我接受了这份采访精神分裂症患者的工作，因为它找到了我，而且似乎是我唯一的选择。这似乎是命中注定的，是一种无法逃避的业力回响。这份工作只是暂时的，只是为了度过这个夏天。有人告诉我，他们需要一个愿意开车跑遍全州，穿过那些小镇，去寻找那些经常漂泊不定、喜欢躲藏的个体的人。我喜欢开车，喜欢旅行，也喜欢那种追求的感觉，所以我接受并完成了这份工作，而我的生活也从此改变了。
The patient is 21 years old and has lived with his parents since his discharge from the army. He has no friends, no recreational activities, and no social life. He spends his time writing and reading, but these activities do not give him any pleasure. He has lost weight, has general anxiety and loss of libido, and occasional feelings of unreality. He is worried about his unpredictable behavior-- for example, getting down on all fours and chewing the grass because he was thinking what it would be like to be a cow.
患者21岁，自从从军队退伍后一直与父母同住。他没有朋友，没有娱乐活动，也没有社交生活。他把时间都花在写字和看书上，但这些活动并不能给他带来任何乐趣。他体重下降，有普遍性的焦虑和性欲减退，并偶尔有不真实感。他很担心自己不可预测的行为——例如，四肢着地去吃草，因为他在想当一头牛是什么感觉。
The patient is 25 years old and believes that she is the devil, and therefore responsible for all the evil in the world. She's not been out of her house for seven days, and only comes down from her room for meals. A few days ago, her mother walked into her room and found her crying. She asked her mother what was the most painful punishment that one human being could inflict upon another.
患者25岁，相信自己就是魔鬼，因此应对世界上所有的邪恶负责。她已经七天没有出门了，只有吃饭时才从房间下来。几天前，她母亲走进房间发现她在哭。她问母亲，人类能给另一个人施加的最痛苦的惩罚是什么。
The mother tried to get the reason for this question, and her daughter mumbled something about the devil having to be punished for the benefit of humanity, something about having to die for his sins. When the mother asked her if she still thought she was the devil, she answered, "Let's not get into that again. It only upsets you and you don't believe me anyway, even when the evidence is all around you, plain for you to see."
母亲试图探寻她问这个问题的原因，女儿含糊其辞地说魔鬼为了人类的福祉必须受到惩罚，还说必须为自己的罪孽而死。当母亲问她是否仍然认为自己是魔鬼时，她回答道：“我们别再谈这个了。这只会让你难过，而且无论证据多么显而易见，你反正也不相信我。”
The people I interview are all so sad, so lonely with such thin souls, like ghosts and demons have invaded their hearts and are sucking their souls dry. A person's soul should be like an ocean, but a schizophrenic's soul is like a pool of rain in a parking lot. They suffer and they are completely alone in their suffering, and there's nothing I can do, nothing anyone can do to bring them back. I come home at night and cry. I sob like a three-year-old.
我采访的人都非常悲伤，非常孤独，灵魂枯瘦，就像鬼魂和恶魔入侵了他们的心脏，吸干了他们的灵魂。一个人的灵魂本该像海洋，但精神分裂症患者的灵魂却像停车场里的积水。他们饱受折磨，在痛苦中完全孤独，我无能为力，没有任何人能把他们拉回来。我晚上回到家就会哭泣，像个三岁的孩子一样嚎啕大哭。
Today, halfway through an interview with a man in Tooele, he says, "I have a crystal in my pouch. Do you want to see it?" I say OK and he takes it out, a normal crystal the size of a large paper clip. And he says, "I can look through this and it will tell me whether you're a good person or a bad person. What do you want me to do? Do you want me to look through it or not?"
今天，在图埃勒（Tooele）采访一名男子时，进行到一半，他说：“我的小袋子里有一块水晶，你想看吗？”我说好，他拿了出来，是一块普通的大回形针大小的水晶。他说：“我可以通过它看到你是一个好人还是坏人。你想让我怎么做？你想让我看吗？”
My first thought is to say, "Do you want to go on with the interview? Maybe when we're done, you can look through the crystal." But then I realize that he's really asking me to take his test, just like I'm asking him to take mine. I come into his house. I ask him very personal questions, and I expect him to answer honestly. And why should he? So I say, "OK, go ahead."
我的第一反应是说：“你想继续采访吗？也许等我们做完，你再看水晶。”但后来我意识到他其实是想让我接受他的测试，就像我要求他接受我的测试一样。我走进他的家，问他非常私人的问题，并期望他诚实回答。可他为什么要诚实回答呢？所以我说：“好吧，你来吧。”
And he puts the crystal up to his eye, turns it clockwise and counterclockwise, back and forth, squinting, looking me up and down, and he says, "I can't tell for sure. I'm going to have to read your mind. Here, take my hand." He holds out his right hand with the crystal resting in the palm. I take his hand and he puts his left hand over mine and squeezes it tight and shakes it, and goes into a small spasm. Then he lets go and sort of sits back like he's exhausted.
他把水晶放在眼睛前，顺时针和逆时针来回转动，眯着眼睛上下打量我，然后说：“我不能确定。我得读读你的思想。来，把手给我。”他伸出右手，水晶放在手心里。我握住他的手，他把左手盖在我的手上，用力捏紧并摇晃，然后进入了一阵小小的痉挛。随后他松开手，坐在那里，看起来筋疲力尽。
He asks me if I felt anything, and I say, "Well, maybe a little." And he says, "I sent you a message. I put it in your mind. I told you what is wrong with me."
他问我感觉到了什么吗，我说：“嗯，可能有一点。”他说：“我给你发了条信息。我把它放进你的脑子里了。我告诉你我哪里出问题了。”
I'm not supposed to figure out what's wrong with these people. I'm just supposed to ask the questions and score the answers from one to seven. This is partly because I'm not a doctor and might get something going that I wouldn't know how to contain, but it's mainly because my supervisors want clean data. They want all the people asking the questions to be doing it in the same way. I'm not supposed to get emotional. I'm not supposed to let the patient get emotional. The therapy part of the county mental health system is in another department. I wouldn't even know what number to call, and I've been told more than once not to worry about it. I should never have let him take the crystal out of his pouch.
我不应该去搞清楚这些人出了什么问题。我只是被要求问问题，然后给答案打分，从一到七。这部分是因为我不是医生，可能会引发一些我不知道如何控制的情况，但主要是因为我的主管们想要干净的数据。他们希望所有提问的人都用同样的方式去做。我不应该带入情绪，也不应该让患者带入情绪。县心理健康系统的治疗部分在另一个部门。我甚至不知道该拨打什么号码，而且不止一次被告知不要担心这个。我不该让他把水晶从袋子里拿出来的。
I drove around all day trying to find a Navajo man. He lives very close to the Four Corners, the cross where Utah, Colorado, New Mexico, and Arizona meet. It's all dirt roads, a house every five miles or so, no addresses, no phones. I stop at every house and knock on the door, but either nobody's home or nobody will answer. I flag down every car that passes and ask directions, and the people offer complicated directions that I follow as best as possible, sometimes driving for 20 or 30 miles. But it's always the wrong place, or nobody's home, or there just isn't a house there at all.
我开了一整天的车想找一名纳瓦霍族男子。他住在离“四角地带”（Four Corners）非常近的地方，也就是犹他州、科罗拉多州、新墨西哥州和亚利桑那州的交界处。那里全是土路，每五英里左右才有一户人家，没有地址，没有电话。我在每一户人家门前停下并敲门，要么没人，要么没人应答。我拦下每一辆路过的汽车询问方向，人们给出的指示很复杂，我尽可能照着做，有时要开二三十英里。但要么找错了地方，要么没人，要么根本就没有房子。
Driving around, I think about how I have some of the same problems as the people I interview. I'm angry, depressed, prone to paranoid delusions, and I worry a lot. Up to now, I thought these were common problems and that I was more or less able to control them. But now I don't know. I feel like I'm just faking it.
开车的时候，我想到我和我采访的人有同样的困扰。我愤怒、沮丧、容易产生偏执的妄想，而且我很焦虑。到现在为止，我一直认为这些是普遍的问题，我或多或少能控制它们。但现在我不知道了。我觉得我只是在伪装。
Eventually, late in the afternoon, I find the man, or at least I think he's the man. I'm a third of the way through the test before I realize he's not the right guy.
最后，在傍晚时分，我找到了那个人，或者至少我觉得是那个人。测试进行到三分之一时，我才意识到他找错了人。
"When was your last visit to a mental health clinic?"
“你上次去心理健康诊所是什么时候？”
"I don't go to a clinic."
“我不去诊所。”
"When did you last see a doctor?"
“你上次看医生是什么时候？”
"I don't have a doctor."
“我没有医生。”
"Do you blame yourself for anything you've done or not done?"
“你对自己做过或没做过的事情自责吗？”
"No."
“没有。”
"Have you felt more self-confident than usual?"
“你是否感到比平时更有自信？”
"No."
“没有。”
"Have you heard voices or other things that weren't there, or that other people couldn't hear, or seen things that weren't there?"
“你是否听到了不存在的声音或其他东西，或者是其他人听不到的声音，或者看到了不存在的东西？”
And he says, "I think you want to talk to my son." And I ask him what his son's name is and he says, "Same as mine."
他说：“我想你应该和我儿子谈谈。”我问他儿子叫什么名字，他说：“和我的一样。”
I come back the next morning and interview the son in the kitchen. They make coffee for me on a propane camp stove, as the house has no electricity. The son is 19 years old, a good-looking kid, tall, healthy. He says he used to run cross-country in high school. He seems to be fine, but as I go through the questions, he starts to fix his eyes on mine, a direct, almost hypnotic stare straight into my head, like he's trying to pull me in and trap me. I try to look back, to look just as deeply into his mind, but it's like looking into a cave.
第二天早上我又回来，在厨房里采访了他的儿子。他们用丙烷露营炉为我煮咖啡，因为房子里没有电。儿子19岁，长得很帅，高大健康。他说他以前在高中时跑越野赛。他看起来很正常，但随着我进行问答，他的眼睛开始紧盯着我，那是一种直视我大脑深处的、近乎催眠的凝视，就像他想把我拉进去困住我一样。我试着回望，试图同样深入地看他的内心，但这就像望着一个洞穴。
He says he hears voices, satanic voices, and that he worries a lot about his shoes, that they're not the right kind, not the kind he sees on MTV. I can't tell if he's sick or if he's just trying to torture me, and I drive away thinking I don't know anything about this disease, that I know even less than when I started. I spent two days driving around, and I made $30, and I feel really, really tired.
他说他听到了声音，撒旦的声音，而且他很担心自己的鞋子，觉得那不是合适的种类，不是他在MTV上看到的。我无法分辨他是真的生病了，还是只是在折磨我。我开车离开时心想，我对这种疾病一无所知，比我开始时了解得还要少。我花了整整两天时间开车，赚了30美元，感觉非常、非常疲惫。
The house is dark, as all the windows have heavy curtains pulled nearly shut. The curtains over the big picture window in the living room are open just a bit, and the light cuts through like a laser beam and hits the red shag carpet, throwing up small dust particles and cigarette ash. Two feet away from the light, near the television, is a slice of pizza lying upside down in the carpet. I'm interviewing the woman, a mother, and her teenage daughter is on the phone talking to her boyfriend, or rather a series of boyfriends, who call and call, and all of them want her to go out right now. But her mother won't let her.
房子里很暗，所有的窗户都拉着厚厚的窗帘，几乎关死。客厅大落地窗上的窗帘只开了一点点，光线像激光一样穿透进来，照在红色长绒地毯上，激起细小的灰尘和烟灰。距离光束两英尺远的地方，电视机附近，有一片比萨饼倒扣在地毯上。我正在采访那位女主人，她的十几岁女儿在电话里和男友，或者说是一连串打来电话的男友们说话，他们都想让她现在就出去。但她母亲不让。
She's trying to answer my questions, trying to concentrate and be polite, but she's mainly listening to what her daughter is saying on the phone, and will suddenly switch from saying, "No, no, I've been feeling fine, I haven't had a relapse in months," to screaming out, "Is that John? I told you never to talk to him again," or "Who is it? Is it a boy? You can't go out. Tell him he has to come over here."
她试图回答我的问题，试图集中注意力并保持礼貌，但她主要是在听女儿在电话里说些什么，会突然从说“不，不，我感觉很好，我已经好几个月没有复发了”，转变为尖叫道：“那是约翰吗？我告诉过你永远不要再和他说话了，”或者“是谁？是个男孩吗？你不能出去。告诉他，让他过来这儿。”
I can't stop looking at the slice of pizza on the carpet. I keep looking at the slice of pizza, because it's the only clue that the woman is sick. I mean she has a teenage daughter and a dirty house, and maybe she shouldn't try to wear makeup to bed, but these are not necessarily symptoms of schizophrenia. She seems to be fine, just worn out, until I get to the question, "Have you been worrying a lot?"
我无法停止注视地毯上的那片比萨。我一直盯着它看，因为那是她病了的唯一线索。我是说，她有一个十几岁的女儿，家里很脏，或许她不该化着妆睡觉，但这些并不一定是精神分裂症的症状。她看起来很正常，只是精疲力竭，直到我问到这个问题：“你最近担心得很多吗？”
And she says, yes, she has. She's been worrying a lot that the elders of the church, the Mormon church, will take her daughter away from her. And I ask her why, and she says because she stopped taking her medication. And I ask her, "Why did you stop taking your medication?" And she says that the only reason she takes it is because she told her bishop that she was visited by the archangel Gabriel and that she'd had sex with him. And then she was also visited by the archangel Michael, and that she'd had sex with both of them at once, and that they'd ravished her almost every night.
她说，是的，她担心很多。她很担心教会——摩门教——的长老会把她的女儿从她身边带走。我问她为什么，她说因为她停止服药了。我问她：“你为什么要停止服药？”她说她吃药的唯一原因是她告诉主教说她被加百列大天使造访了，并和他发生了性关系。然后她又被米迦勒大天使造访了，她和他们两个同时发生了性关系，他们几乎每天晚上都强暴她。
So her bishop made her go to a doctor, and the doctor gave her some pills, and she took the pills, and the angels stopped coming. The bishop and the elders had told her that if she had sex with any more angels, they'd take her daughter away. So I asked her again why she stopped taking her medication and she says, "I'm lonely. I miss them. I want them to come back."
于是她的主教让她去看医生，医生给了她一些药，她吃了药，天使就不再来了。主教和长老们告诉她，如果她再和天使发生性关系，他们就会把她的女儿带走。所以我再次问她为什么要停止服药，她说：“我感到孤独。我想念他们。我希望他们回来。”
Today in a restaurant, eating lunch between interviews, I decided to take the test. I answered the questions and scored myself appropriately, and at some point I realized I wasn't doing so well. I decided not to even add up the points, because then I'd be left with a score and I'd never forget it. If I were to write a report on myself, it would sound something like this.
今天在一家餐馆里，在两次采访之间吃午饭时，我决定做一下这个测试。我回答了问题，给自己打了分，在某个时刻我意识到我做得并不好。我决定甚至不去统计分数，因为那样我就有了分数，而且我永远也忘不掉它。如果我要写一份关于我自己的报告，它听起来会是这样的。
The patient is 36 years old and lives alone since his wife left him three weeks ago. She took the kids and all the silverware except for a large knife and a bowl and a coffee cup. The patient admits that her leaving may have had something to do with the fact that, without warning, he completely gutted the house, tore out all the walls and ceilings, all the lath and plaster, right down to the studs. He says he did this in order to live like a primitive. When asked if he was successful, he says it was the first step in the right direction.
患者36岁，自妻子三周前离开后独自居住。她带走了孩子和所有的餐具，只留下了一把大刀、一个碗和一个咖啡杯。患者承认她的离开可能与他毫无预兆地彻底拆毁了房子，拆掉了所有的墙壁和天花板，所有的板条和石膏，一直拆到龙骨有关。他说他这样做是为了像原始人一样生活。当被问及他是否成功时，他说这是朝正确方向迈出的第一步。
The patient is a 36-year-old male who lives alone since his wife and children left him two months ago. He says there's a darkness that separates him from other people, a heavy darkness like looking at a person from the bottom of a well. He believes that if he could say the right words, then the darkness would go away. He says he sometimes knows the right words but cannot say them. Other times, he can't even think of the words to say.
患者是一名36岁的男性，自妻子和孩子两个月前离开后独自生活。他说有一种黑暗将他与其他人隔开，那是一种厚重的黑暗，就像从井底看人一样。他相信如果能说出正确的词，那么黑暗就会消失。他说他有时知道正确的词，但无法说出来。其他时候，他甚至想不出该说什么词。
The patient is 36 years old and lives alone since his wife and children left him three months ago. Last week he went fishing in the San Juans, and now believes that there's no better fisherman than himself. He says, "I can't tell you about it, because talking about fishing is silly, like farting and tap dancing at the same time. All I can say is I walk around in the water, and I know the instant the fish will jump for the fly. I cut open their stomachs and squeeze out the bugs in my hand, study what they eat, how it all gets digested, even the exoskeleton and wings." He says he was sick before, but now he's OK, and that it was the fly rod, just holding the rod in his hand, that cured him. His house is clean. The electricity is on. The walls have been sheetrocked and painted white. He says, "I'll have to ask her, beg her, and maybe she'll come back."
患者36岁，自妻子和孩子三个月前离开后独自生活。上周他在圣胡安垂钓，现在认为没有比他更好的渔夫了。他说：“我没法告诉你，因为谈论钓鱼很愚蠢，就像一边放屁一边跳踢踏舞。我只能说，我走在水里，我知道鱼什么时候会去咬钩。我切开它们的胃，在手里挤出虫子，研究它们吃什么，这一切是如何消化的，甚至是外骨骼和翅膀。”他说他以前病了，但现在好了，是飞钓竿，仅仅是手里拿着鱼竿，治愈了他。他的房子很干净。电通着。墙壁已经重新封板并刷成了白色。他说：“我得求她，恳求她，也许她会回来。”
[MUSIC -- "I TRAVEL ALONE" BY NOEL COWARD]
[音乐 -- 诺埃尔·考沃德的《我独自旅行》]
Act Two, The Friendly Man. There are three kids. There's a house. There's a marriage. What Scott wanted was a steady job with bosses he did not hate and who did not hate him. He found that job, for a short time, in commercial radio.
第二部分：友善的人。有三个孩子，有一个家，有一段婚姻。斯科特想要的是一份稳定的工作，老板他不讨厌，老板也不讨厌他。他在商业广播电台短暂地找到了这份工作。
There are a lot of bad ways to wake up, but surely one of the worst is by looking into the flood light from a police car. I was in a field, some farmer's field next to a power plant just outside Lawrence, Kansas. I was sleeping there next to my car before driving into Kansas City in the morning. The policeman somehow saw my car from the road, and they pulled up right in front of it, and I didn't even wake up.
醒来的方式有很多种坏的，但最糟糕的一种绝对是看着警车的探照灯醒来。当时我在堪萨斯州劳伦斯郊外一个发电厂旁边的田野里。在第二天早上开车前往堪萨斯城之前，我就在那儿靠着车睡觉。警察不知怎么从路上看到了我的车，他们直接停在车前，我甚至都没醒。
I was lying on the ground on the passenger side of the car, and when I did wake up, one of the policemen was in the front seat, I guess looking for drugs, and the other was 40 feet away in the hay field. And I don't know why he was out there, unless he had his gun pulled, covering this partner. He said I scared him when I woke up so suddenly. I sat straight up. Boom, awake. And I bet he nearly shot me dead.
我当时躺在副驾驶那边的地上，当我醒来时，一个警察正在前座，我想是在搜毒品，另一个在40英尺外的干草地里。我不知道他为什么在那里，除非他拔枪掩护同伴。他说我醒得太突然，把他吓坏了。我猛地坐起来。砰，醒了。我打赌他差点把我当场击毙。
They wanted to know what I was doing sleeping in the field, and I told them that I didn't like motels, which was only partly true. So I decided to tell them that I was born here in Lawrence, but that I don't live here anymore, which was completely true but somehow didn't achieve the level of meaning I hoped it would. They asked me what I was going to do in Kansas City, and I said I was going to interview the mayor at 11:00 in the morning. I told them I was a producer for a radio program. I told them the name of the program and the name of the host, and they'd heard of him. You'd know who he is as well, if I were to say his name, but I've decided not to say his name and call him the Friendly Man instead, because this is his persona.
他们想知道我为什么睡在田野里，我告诉他们我不喜欢汽车旅馆，但这只说对了一部分。于是我决定告诉他们我出生在劳伦斯，但现在不住在这里，这完全属实，但不知为何没达到我希望的那种深度。他们问我到堪萨斯城要做什么，我说我上午11点要采访市长。我告诉他们我是某广播节目的制作人。我说了节目的名字和主持人的名字，他们听过那个节目。如果我报出他的名字，你也会知道他是谁，但我决定不说出他的名字，称他为“友善的人”，因为这是他的人设。
I told the policemen that every weekday morning, the Friendly Man has a five-minute feed on one of the networks, and 12 million people listen. His stories are, as a rule, upbeat and positive. Their general theme is people taking responsibility for their lives, their community, their country. The Friendly Man always has good news, and the good news is always that America just keeps getting better and better. Both policemen said they had heard of the program and that they liked the Friendly Man, and so they decided they liked me as well, and that it was OK to sleep in the field, sorry to have bothered you.
我告诉警察，每个工作日的早晨，“友善的人”在网络电台都有五分钟的节目，有1200万人收听。他的故事通常是积极向上的。总的主题是人们对自己的生活、社区和国家负责。“友善的人”总有好消息，而好消息总是美国在变得越来越好。两位警察都说他们听过那个节目，喜欢“友善的人”，所以他们决定他们也喜欢我，睡在田野里没关系，抱歉打扰你了。
I was hired by one of the Friendly Man's executive producers. Her job was to wrangle and corral radio producers like myself from around the country into conducting interviews and writing scripts for stories that had been found by her flock of computer researchers, also from around the country. Some people are surprised to hear that the Friendly Man doesn't actually produce the stories he tells, but in reality he just doesn't have the time, what with the television show now and the specials and so on. It's not that he doesn't want to write his stories, not that he can't. It's just that he's really busy now, being the Friendly Man, and you shouldn't expect him to come up with all of his own material.
我受雇于“友善的人”的一位执行制片人。她的工作是统筹和管理像我这样遍布全国的广播制作人，让他们进行采访并撰写故事脚本，这些故事是由她手下的一群同样遍布全国的计算机研究人员发现的。有些人听到“友善的人”其实并不亲自制作故事会感到惊讶，但实际上他只是没时间，毕竟还有电视节目、特别节目等等。并不是他不想写自己的故事，也不是他不能写。只是他现在忙着当“友善的人”，你不应该指望他自己提供所有素材。
The way it works is that the Friendly Man is in New York with maybe a couple of editors and an engineer. And his executive producer is in San Francisco with fax machines and email. And the researchers are all over the place, looking for story ideas through computer searches. When the researcher finds what looks like an appropriate story, he calls the people in the story on the phone and talks to them for a while. Then he writes out a story synopsis, which is sent to the Friendly Man for approval. Once approved, the story goes to a producer and the producer is in charge of conducting, basically, the same interviews all over again, on tape this time, and then editing the tape and writing the script, which is reviewed by the executive producer in San Francisco and sent to the Friendly Man in New York City so he can read it on the air.
运作方式是这样的，“友善的人”在纽约，带着几个编辑和一个工程师。他的执行制片人在旧金山，用着传真机和电子邮件。研究人员遍布各地，通过计算机搜索寻找故事创意。当研究员发现看起来合适的故事时，他会通过电话联系故事中的人，交谈一段时间。然后写出一份故事梗概，发给“友善的人”审批。一旦批准，故事就会交给一名制作人，制作人负责基本上重新进行所有的采访，这次是有录音的，然后编辑录音并撰写脚本，脚本由旧金山的执行制片人审阅，并发送给纽约的“友善的人”，这样他就可以在节目中播读。
The first story I produced for the Friendly Man was in Tucson, Arizona. It was about some people in Tucson who were helping to make America a better place. It doesn't really matter what the story was about. What matters is that I had to do all the interviews over the phone. There wasn't enough money to send me to Tucson. So I found an audio engineer in Tucson and had him go to the locations and hold a microphone up to the subjects while I talked to them on the phone. Then he sent me the tape, which I edited and then wrote the script without ever meeting the people I was writing about or the person I was writing for.
我为“友善的人”制作的第一个故事是在亚利桑那州的图森。是关于图森的一些人正在帮助美国变得更好。故事的内容并不重要。重要的是我必须通过电话完成所有的采访。没有足够的资金送我去图森。所以我找了一位图森的音频工程师，让他去现场，当我通过电话与采访对象交谈时，让他拿着麦克风对着他们。然后他把录音发给我，我进行剪辑并写出脚本，而我从未见过我所写的人，也没有见过我所写的那个人。
When I made a suggestion for changing the story, a change that I thought would make it better, the executive producer said that she would try not to get upset with me because this was my first story, and maybe I didn't understand my role. The story had been approved as written in the synopsis. There were to be no changes, no additional narratives or discoveries. I was but the writer-producer, one of many cogs in the wheel. I apologized and did the story as ordered.
当我建议修改故事，一个我认为会更好的修改时，执行制片人说她会尽量不对我生气，因为这是我的第一个故事，也许我不了解自己的角色。故事已经按照梗概批准了。不能有任何更改，不能有额外的叙述或发现。我只是那个写脚本的制作人，轮子上的一个零件。我道歉并按照命令完成了故事。
After this first story, I asked the executive producer if I could go on the road, drive around and collect interviews, actually meet the people and see what they were doing, and then come back and produce the stories. She gave me four stories at a distance of 3,000 miles. They would pay the mileage but would give me nothing up front. The food and lodging were to be my expenses, and so I was sleeping out. It was the first week of July and so warm at night you could sleep on the grass without a bag or a blanket.
第一个故事之后，我问执行制片人我是否可以上路，开车到处转转，收集采访，真正地去见见人们并看看他们在做什么，然后回来制作故事。她给了我四个故事，距离有3000英里。他们会支付里程费，但预付什么都不会给。伙食和住宿由我承担，所以我得露宿。那是7月初，夜晚很温暖，你可以睡在草地上，不需要袋子或毯子。
At 11:00 AM, on the morning after the incident with the police, I was standing in the mayor's office on the top floor of the Kansas City, Missouri municipal building. It's a tall building, built on one of the highest hills in the area, so looking out of the window, I could see most of the city, buildings and railroad tracks and the river-- the Missouri River-- making a big ox-bow right through town. We sat at a long wooden table, a conference table, in tall chairs. Mayor Emanuel Cleaver, also a Methodist minister, a black mayor in a black town.
上午11点，在与警察发生那件事后的第二天早上，我站在堪萨斯城密苏里市政大楼顶层的市长办公室里。这是一座高楼，建在该地区最高的山丘之一上，所以从窗户望去，我可以看到这座城市的大部分地区，建筑、铁轨和河流——密苏里河——在城中绕了一个大大的牛轭。我们坐在长木桌旁，一张会议桌，坐在高背椅上。市长伊曼纽尔·克利弗（Emanuel Cleaver）也是一位卫理公会牧师，一个黑人城市里的黑人市长。
I'd come to ask him about his summertime midnight basketball program. The program, like all midnight basketball programs, was designed to reduce the crime rate by keeping juveniles off the street. And, like with some of the other programs, the crime rate hadn't gotten any better except for the time that the kids were actually playing basketball. Whenever there was a game going on, the crime rate in the neighborhood was lower.
我是来问他关于他夏季午夜篮球项目的事。这个项目，像所有午夜篮球项目一样，旨在通过让青少年远离街道来降低犯罪率。而且，和其他一些项目一样，除了孩子们真正打篮球的时间外，犯罪率并没有好转。每当有比赛进行时，附近的犯罪率确实较低。
The mayor's opponents were saying that the program was pork, that the $100,000 a year could be better spent somewhere else. I asked the mayor about this, and he was adamant, even passionate, about the value of teaching kids to play basketball or any team sport. He said that team sports teach kids the best values, that they learn to cooperate and play by the rules. They learn to problem-solve through cooperation, and by playing, they learn to love the game, and through the love of the game, they learn to love themselves and each other.
市长的反对者说这个项目是在浪费公款，10万美元一年的经费花在其他地方会更好。我问市长这个问题，他非常坚定，甚至充满激情，谈论教孩子打篮球或任何团队运动的价值。他说团队运动教给孩子们最好的价值观，他们学会合作并遵守规则。他们学会通过合作解决问题，通过比赛，他们学会热爱这项运动，通过对运动的热爱，他们学会爱自己和彼此。
He said that a few of the kids had gone to college on basketball scholarships, and this gave hope to everybody in the community, a community where hope was like a foreign language. And that alone was worth it, even a bargain at $100,000. He said, "You go to the games. It's mothers, fathers, sisters, brothers. You'll see the whole community there."
他说有几个孩子靠篮球奖学金上了大学，这给了整个社区希望，一个希望像外语一样遥远的社区。仅这一点就值了，甚至这10万美元也是一笔划算的交易。他说：“你去看看比赛。有妈妈、爸爸、姐妹、兄弟。你会看到整个社区都在那里。”
He was right. Over on the east side, the poor side of town, there were games going on in a community center and the place was packed. And the games were good, little eight- and nine-year-olds passing the ball and making plays and running hard the whole game. They loved the game. I interviewed coaches, kids, and parents, and everything was going fine. Things really were getting better and better in America.
他是对的。在东区，城市的贫困区，社区中心正在进行比赛，里面挤满了人。比赛打得很好，八九岁的小孩在传球、配合，整场比赛跑得很卖力。他们热爱这项运动。我采访了教练、孩子和家长，一切都很顺利。美国的事情确实在变得越来越好。
But then, just before I left, I was talking to a father about a son, and somebody-- I think probably a little kid-- took my three rechargeable batteries and a digital audiotape with the mayor's interview on it out of my bag and out of the building. And they were gone. The batteries were worth $250 and could be replaced, but the interview with the mayor was lost for good. Some little kid looked in my bag and these things were like eggs in a basket. Anyone older would've just taken the bag.
但就在我离开前，我正在和一位父亲谈论他的儿子，有人——我想可能是一个小孩子——从我的包里偷走了我的三节充电电池和一盘带有市长采访的数字录音带，然后带出了大楼。它们不见了。电池价值250美元，可以更换，但市长的采访永远丢了。某个小孩往我包里一看，这些东西就像篮子里的鸡蛋。如果是大一点的人，直接把包拿走了。
I walked around the neighborhood for a while, trying to figure out what to do. The next day was a Saturday and I doubted the mayor would be in his office, which would mean that I'd have to wait until Monday. But I had appointments for interviews Monday morning for another story in St. Louis, 300 miles to the east. And then there was the fact that I'd been robbed while doing a story about a program that reduces juvenile crime.
我在附近走了走，试图想出该怎么办。第二天是周六，我怀疑市长不在办公室，这意味着我得等到周一。但我周一早上有另一个故事的采访预约，在300英里外的圣路易斯。还有个事实是，我因为做一个关于减少青少年犯罪项目的报道而被抢了。
The story, as it was written by the researcher in the synopsis, was all about how black people were improving their lives and making things better by playing basketball. But the reality of the situation, at least the way I saw it, was that these people were poor, that they'd been poor for a long time, and that they were probably going to stay poor for a long time. So I called the executive producer and left her a message, saying that maybe she should consider scrapping the basketball story, and that I was going on to St. Louis and would call her from there.
研究人员在梗概中写的故事，全都是关于黑人如何通过打篮球改善生活并使事情变得更好。但现实情况，至少在我看来，是这些人很穷，他们已经穷了很久，而且他们可能在很长一段时间内还会继续穷下去。所以我给执行制片人打了电话并留言，说也许她应该考虑放弃这个篮球故事，我正要去圣路易斯，会从那里给她打电话。
The story in St. Louis was also about poor black people, only in St. Louis it was about old poor black people, old poor black people who lived in a nursing home and had started their own private economy, wherein they'd get paid for helping each other out by washing clothes or cooking meals or even reading books and stories out loud at bedtime. But they didn't get paid in real money. They got paid in what they called time dollars, which could only be exchanged between themselves or cashed in at a special community store for food, clothing, and other necessary items.
圣路易斯的故事也是关于贫穷的黑人，只是在圣路易斯它是关于贫穷的老年黑人，住在养老院里并开始了他们自己的私人经济，他们通过互相帮助洗衣服、做饭，甚至在睡前朗读书籍和故事来获得报酬。但他们得到的不是真正的钱。他们得到的是所谓的“时间美元”，只能在他们之间兑换，或者在特别的社区商店兑换食品、衣服和其他必要物品。
The old people liked the time dollar program. They were much happier than before they had the time dollar program. At least this is what the researcher had written in the synopsis, and this is how things seemed for most of the morning I was there doing interviews.
老人们喜欢时间美元计划。他们比拥有时间美元计划之前快乐多了。至少这是研究人员在梗概中写的，而且我进行采访的大部分时间里事情看起来确实如此。
My first interview was with the woman who'd set everything up. She was a well-educated upper-middle-class white lady who worked for a large charitable organization as a local manager of its programs. This woman was very nervous, and I couldn't tell if it was because she was just nervous being interviewed, or if she was nervous being surrounded by poor black people, or if she was just nervous by nature.
我的第一次采访是和那个建立这一切的女性进行的。她是一位受过良好教育的中上阶层白人女士，为一家大型慈善机构工作，担任其项目的当地经理。这个女人非常紧张，我看不出是因为她被采访感到紧张，还是因为被贫穷的黑人包围感到紧张，还是她天生就紧张。
I talked to her for a while, and then she introduced me to some women who actually participated in the time dollar program. And they told me that they do things like call up old people around town and ask them if they feel OK, if they're sick or something. Or they clean and dry a neighbor's clothes before he goes into the hospital, for cook for someone who has bad asthma. And then they could use the time dollars to buy stuff they needed.
我和她聊了一会儿，然后她向我介绍了几个真正参与时间美元计划的妇女。她们告诉我，她们做的事情包括给城里的老人们打电话，问他们感觉好不好，是不是生病了什么的。或者在邻居住院前帮他洗衣服、晒衣服，或者为患有严重哮喘的人做饭。然后她们可以用时间美元购买她们需要的东西。
They were friendly ladies, and it was just like it said in the synopsis-- neighbors helping neighbors and getting paid to do it. So I asked them if we could go over and see the store, the place where they actually buy everything. And they sort of hemmed and hawed about it, said there was a key and they'd have to get it. And then we were talking about grandchildren, arthritis, the weather in Mississippi.
她们是友善的女士，一切都像梗概里写的那样——邻里互助并因此获得报酬。所以我问她们我们能不能过去看看商店，就是她们真正购买所有东西的地方。她们支支吾吾地推脱，说要一把钥匙，她们得去拿。然后我们就聊起了孙辈、关节炎、密西西比的天气。
I was wondering if maybe they didn't really want to go to the store, so I asked again, and they said it was a couple of blocks away and it was raining so hard. I was a little worried at this point, because the store was in the synopsis and so there had to be some tape of the store in the story. And so I explained my predicament to the women and begged them, as best I could, if we could go there.
我纳闷她们是不是真的不想去商店，所以我又问了一遍，她们说商店在几个街区外，而且雨下得太大了。我此时有点担心，因为商店在梗概里，所以故事里必须要有商店的录音。所以我向她们解释了我的困境，并尽可能地恳求她们，问我们能不能去那里。
We borrowed some umbrellas and walked over to the building that housed the store. It was a one-story warehouse, brick and concrete, a few windows. Inside, we went down a hallway that separated two large rooms, each packed with desks and office people, stacks of paper, stacks of folders, desk fans, lots of desk lights, people typing on real typewriters, old adding machines. It was very suspicious. One side looked like the Bulgarian foreign trade department, the other side like the Lithuanian shipping commission. Down at the far, dark end of the hall was a large metal cabinet with two full length doors, closed by a padlock. One of the ladies opened the lock, and inside were four shelves. The top held bottles of fabric softener. The next was full of baby wipes. Another had some paper plates and plastic silverware, and the bottom was full of bathroom deodorizer.
我们借了一些雨伞，走到了存放商店的那栋楼。那是一个单层仓库，砖石和混凝土结构，有几扇窗户。进去后，我们沿着一条走廊，走廊将两个大房间隔开，每个房间都挤满了办公桌和办公人员、成堆的文件、成堆的文件夹、台式风扇、很多台灯，人们用真正的打字机打字，用着旧加法机。这非常可疑。一边看起来像保加利亚外贸部，另一边像立陶宛航运委员会。走廊尽头的黑暗处是一个巨大的金属柜，有两扇全高的门，锁着挂锁。其中一位女士打开锁，里面有四层架子。顶部放着瓶装的织物柔软剂。下一层装满了婴儿湿巾。还有一层放着一些纸盘和塑料餐具，底部装满了厕所除臭剂。
That was it. That was the store. I'd imagined something between a 7-Eleven and a thrift store, and I didn't understand. I didn't understand how any of this was working. I stood there and looked at the cabinet and the story disintegrated into baby wipes and picnic forks.
就是这些。那就是商店。我原本想象的是介于7-Eleven便利店和旧货店之间的东西，我没看懂。我不明白这一切是怎么运作的。我站在那里看着那个柜子，故事瞬间瓦解成婴儿湿巾和野餐叉。
I thanked the ladies and left the building and called the executive producer. I didn't want to tell her about the baby wipes and the fabric softener. There was no use in telling her that something was wrong, that maybe the whole story was a sham. But I did want to ask her if  it would be OK if I left the store out of the story, that maybe the story should be that these people just like helping each other, and that the time money thing wasn't so important. But she never let me get to it.
我谢过女士们，离开了大楼，给执行制片人打了电话。我不想告诉她关于婴儿湿巾和织物柔软剂的事。没必要告诉她哪里出错了，或者整个故事可能是一场骗局。但我确实想问她，如果我把商店从故事里删掉是否可以，也许故事应该是这些人只是喜欢互相帮助，时间金钱的事情没那么重要。但她根本没让我说出来。
She was upset, very upset, about the message I'd left on her machine Friday night. It had ruined her whole weekend. She was distraught and nearly hysterical. Everyone was distraught and nearly hysterical, and it was my fault. My fault to have taken my eyes off the equipment, my fault to have been robbed, my fault to have left town without completing the story assignment. She said that I'd led her to believe that I was a professional, but no professional would ever behave in such a manner.
她很生气，非常生气，关于我周五晚上在电话留言机上留下的信息。它毁了她整个周末。她心烦意乱，近乎歇斯底里。每个人都心烦意乱，近乎歇斯底里，这都是我的错。我的错是没看好设备，我的错是被抢了，我的错是没完成故事任务就离开了小镇。她说她曾误以为我是个专业人士，但没有专业人士会做出这种行为。
She said this twice, the subtext being that the Friendly Man can only use professional producers, and that therefore I was fired unless maybe I went back to Kansas City to re-interview the mayor. My job was to do what I was told, just as their job was to do what they were told, just as the Friendly Man's job was to do what he was told. Because the audience, the 12 million listeners, had something they wanted to be told-- that America is a good place with decent people, never mind the screaming coming from the basement.
她说了两次，潜台词是“友善的人”只能用专业制作人，因此我被解雇了，除非我能回到堪萨斯城重新采访市长。我的工作是听命行事，就像他们的工作是听命行事，就像“友善的人”的工作是听命行事一样。因为受众，那1200万听众，他们想听到一些东西——那就是美国是一个有好人的好地方，别管地下室传来的尖叫声。
So I got in my car and drove 300 west to Kansas City. I could have told them to go [BLEEP] themselves, but I didn't. I went back, because I didn't want to be fired by the Friendly Man. I'd been fired by other, less well-known friendly men, and it's always like being branded, scorned as the one who ran. I was tired of that, tired of being broke and not having any work. My wife, my family-- they were tired of it too. I decided that I wanted to be a professional. I wanted to be a team player. I wanted to take responsibility for my life, my community and my country. I wanted to get ahead and go someplace with my career and be happy.
所以我上了车，向西开了300英里回到堪萨斯城。我本可以让他们滚蛋，但我没有。我回去了，因为我不想被“友善的人”解雇。我被其他不太出名的友善的人解雇过，那种感觉就像被烙上了印记，被视为逃跑的那个人，这很屈辱。我厌倦了那些，厌倦了身无分文且没有工作。我妻子，我的家人——他们也厌倦了。我决定我想成为一名专业人士。我想成为一名团队成员。我想为我的生活、我的社区和我的国家负责。我想在事业上取得进步，去某个地方发展，并获得幸福。
I drove back to Kansas City and got in late at night. I drove through the big buildings downtown, the streets lit yellow and vacant. I drove through the poor neighborhoods, the streets lit yellow and vacant. I drove along the parkways, past fountains and parks, and I drove past my grandmother's house and down to the Country Club Plaza, where I slept without a bag or a blanket on the lawn, on the long esplanade in front of the Nelson Art Museum. If I was to be bothered by the police, I would tell them that I am a radio producer working for the Friendly Man, and that I have a meeting with the mayor in the morning.
我开车回堪萨斯城，深夜才到。我开车经过市中心的大楼，街道在昏黄的灯光下空无一人。我开车经过贫困社区，街道昏黄空旷。我沿着公园大道，经过喷泉和公园，我开车经过祖母的家，下到乡村俱乐部广场，在那里我睡在草坪上，没用袋子或毯子，就在尼尔森艺术博物馆前那条长长的林荫道上。如果警察来找我麻烦，我会告诉他们我是为“友善的人”工作的广播制作人，明天早上和市长有个会议。
Coming up, you can call me Ray or you can call me Jay, but I don't want to know my own name, thank you very much. Amnesiac wannabe forgets to forget. Also, sixth-grader remembers to remember. More stories from Scott Carrier in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，你可以叫我雷或叫我杰伊，但我不想知道我自己的名字，非常感谢。假冒的健忘症患者忘了要忘记。还有，六年级学生记得要记住。一分钟后，国际公共广播电台将继续带来斯科特·卡里尔的更多故事。
Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose some theme, and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Friendly Man, stories by Scott Carrier. We're devoting the full hour to Scott's stories because they're just great radio stories, and they sound great when you listen to them one after another. Each of these stories originally appeared on different episodes of our radio show, most of them back in the 1990s, actually. And there's a point where I made a little collection of these on a CD, and I would duplicate copies and give them to friends now and then. And at some point, I realized, oh, this CD would be a really great hour on the radio. And so that's basically what we have today.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，并带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目是“友善的人”，斯科特·卡里尔的故事。我们把整整一个小时献给斯科特的故事，因为它们是伟大的广播故事，当你一个接一个地听它们时，听感非常好。这些故事原本出现在我们广播节目的不同剧集中，大部分实际上是在20世纪90年代。有一次我把这些录音做成了CD合集，偶尔复制几份给朋友。在某个时刻，我意识到，哦，这张CD在广播里会是一个非常棒的一小时节目。所以这就是我们今天带来的内容。
Scott is just one of the great original voices working in radio. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, Who Am I? What Am I Doing Here? Sometimes all we want to do is forget. All we want is amnesia. But of course, real amnesia happens a lot more on TV and in the movies than it does in real life. In the movies, people are constantly getting bonked on the head and forgetting who they are. And then they embark on a series of madcap adventures that teach them who they really are. But does that happen, the amnesia part at least? Is there really such a thing as amnesia, and does it work like that? Have you ever met a single person who's had amnesia?
斯科特是广播界最伟大的原创声音之一。我们现在进入了节目的第三部分。第三部分：我是谁？我在这里做什么？有时我们只想忘记。我们只想要健忘症。但当然，真正的健忘症在电视和电影里发生的频率远高于现实生活。在电影里，人们不断被人敲头，然后忘了自己是谁。然后他们开始了一系列疯狂的冒险，让他们明白了自己到底是谁。但这真的会发生吗，至少失忆这部分？真的有健忘症这种东西吗，它是这样运作的吗？你见过哪怕一个患有健忘症的人吗？
Well, a few years back, we at This American Life wanted to find out the answer to that. And Scott agreed to help.
嗯，几年前，我们《美国生活》想要找出答案。斯科特同意帮忙。
The idea was to find someone who had amnesia and ask them what it was like in real life. I was warned that it might be difficult to locate such a person, that the affliction may in reality be quite rare, but that there was at least one known amnesiac living in Tennessee, and another in Pennsylvania. The particular cities and addresses could be found if necessary. "Nonsense," I said. "I'm surrounded by amnesiacs. This city breeds forgetfulness. There must be five or six amnesiacs in the neighborhood around my office alone." I accepted the offer, thinking it would be an easy assignment.
当时的想法是找到一个患有健忘症的人，问问他们在现实生活中是什么感觉。我被警告说，找到这样一个人可能很困难，这种疾病在现实中可能非常罕见，但至少在田纳西州有一个已知的健忘症患者，宾夕法尼亚州还有一个。必要时可以找到具体的城市和地址。“胡说，”我说。“我的周围全是健忘症患者。这座城市滋生健忘。单单在我办公室附近的社区里，就有五六个健忘症患者。”我接受了这个任务，认为这会是个简单的差事。
I began by asking everybody I saw if they had or had ever had amnesia. I did this for three days, and I tried not to be selective, but to ask everybody with whom I came into contact, whether my wife or the checker at the grocery store, "Do you have or have you ever had amnesia?" And furthermore, I'd ask this each and every time I saw the person, sometimes two or three times a day. No one admitted to currently having amnesia, but at least one in four remembered being knocked hard on the head and losing memory from a concussion. This kind of amnesia lasts only a few minutes or a few hours, and concussion stories, I found out, are usually not worth listening to or worth telling.
我开始问我看到的每个人，他们是否有过健忘症。我坚持了三天，我尽量不挑剔，而是问每一个我接触到的人，无论是我的妻子还是杂货店的收银员：“你现在有或者曾经患过健忘症吗？”而且，每次我见到他们，我都会问一遍，有时一天问两三次。没有人承认现在患有健忘症，但至少有四分之一的人记得自己被人狠狠敲过头，因为脑震荡失去了记忆。这种健忘症只持续几分钟或几小时，而且我发现脑震荡的故事通常不值得去听，也不值得去讲。
They usually go something like this. "I was in a football game and two guys fell on my head. I kept playing. I played the whole game and everything, but then after the game I had to get a ride home, because I didn't remember where I lived." I heard this story three times from the same person, and each time he told it to me in the same way with some difficulty, as if something had been taken from him and he didn't know what it was.
它们通常是这样的：“我在踢足球，有两个人压在我头上。我继续踢了。我踢完了整场比赛，什么都做了，但赛后我得搭便车回家，因为我不记得自己住哪儿了。”我从同一个人那里听到了三次这个故事，每次他讲给我的方式都一样，带着些困难，仿佛有什么东西从他身上被夺走了，而他不知道那是什么。
Two people admitted to suffering from drug-induced amnesia. One had a drinking problem. The other was myself as, due to the fact that when I was 19, I ate a big psilocybin mushroom right off the ground in the mountains of Colombia, South America, and spent four or five hours where I didn't know my name, where I was, or why. I was hallucinating wildly, the sky exploding, the ground bubbling up under my feet. The trees and bushes were throwing off little packets of flame and brightly colored orbs. I wandered around and around in a cow pasture, holding my hands over my eyes, delirious.
有两个人承认患有药物引起的健忘症。一个是酗酒问题。另一个是我自己，因为在我19岁时，我在南美洲哥伦比亚的山区里直接从地上捡了一个大迷幻蘑菇吃了，度过了四五个小时，不知道自己的名字、身在何处或原因。我当时产生了强烈的幻觉，天空在爆炸，地面在我脚下冒泡。树木和灌木丛喷射出小团火焰和明亮的彩色光球。我转啊转，在一个牛场里走来走去，双手捂着眼睛，神志不清。
And then a man in a jeep picked me up and I thought he might be my father, and I thought I knew what he was saying, but I didn't know what language he was speaking. And we went to his house and watched a soccer game on television, while his wife, who I thought might be my mother, served us coffee from a metal tray. And then I was back out on the road, and I walked up to a park and sat down and drew a picture of myself in a notebook. And below the picture I wrote these words: "I'm still here." If this gave me any insights into what amnesia is like-- real amnesia-- I don't remember what they are.
然后一个开吉普车的男人把我接上了车，我以为他可能是我父亲，我以为我知道他在说什么，但我不知道他在说哪种语言。我们去了他家，在电视上看了场足球赛，他的妻子——我以为可能是我母亲——从金属托盘里给我们端上了咖啡。然后我又回到了路上，我走到一个公园坐下来，在笔记本上画了一张自己的像。在画下面我写了这些话：“我还在。”如果这让我对健忘症是什么——真正的健忘症——有什么见解的话，我不记得它们是什么了。
In three days, the closest I came to finding someone with amnesia was through a young woman who's the daughter of a friend of mine. She's a physical therapist and one of her patients had had her head smashed in a car accident. Her amnesia is kind of the opposite of what we normally think about. She can remember things in the distant past just fine, but she doesn't seem to be able to remember what just happened or what she was just thinking or just where it was she was going. So she can't, for instance, drive a car or even ride a bus. I asked my friend's daughter if I might be able to talk with this woman, and she said, "Well, I guess so, but you might have a better conversation with her dog."
三天里，我最接近找到一个健忘症患者是通过我朋友的女儿，一个年轻女性。她是物理治疗师，她的一个病人在车祸中头部被撞碎了。她的健忘症和我们通常认为的恰恰相反。她对遥远的过去记忆犹新，但似乎记不住刚刚发生了什么，或者她刚才在想什么，或者她到底要去哪儿。所以她不能，比如，开车甚至坐公交车。我问我朋友的女儿我是否能和这位女士谈谈，她说：“好吧，我想可以，但你和她那条狗可能谈得更好。”
I came back to my office feeling a little down. Finding an amnesiac was proving to be more difficult than expected. I decided to seek professional help. I got up out of my chair and walked across the hallway and knocked on the door of Dr. Jeff Harris, psychologist.
我回到办公室，感觉有点低落。事实证明找到一个健忘症患者比预想的要困难得多。我决定寻求专业帮助。我从椅子上站起来，走到走廊对面，敲开了心理学家杰夫·哈里斯（Jeff Harris）博士的门。
I think there was a guy that went through it when I was in Vietnam, who ended up in serious action. And he ended up going from one APC to the next. Each one got blown up as he was getting in, or-- I don't know exactly how he survived the whole thing, but we're talking about a platoon basically getting wiped out, he being one of the few survivors. And he couldn't remember. He couldn't remember his past. He couldn't remember where he was going. And that's the classical Freudian theory of repression. We don't remember things that make us feel guilty, or feel pain.
我想我还在越南的时候有个家伙经历过，最后陷入了激战。他最后从一辆装甲运兵车换到下一辆。每一辆在他上车时都被炸毁了，或者——我不清楚他是怎么活下来的，但我们谈论的是一个排基本上被全歼，他是极少数幸存者之一。他记不起来了。他记不住自己的过去。他记不住自己要往哪里走。这就是弗洛伊德关于压抑的经典理论。我们不记得那些让我们感到内疚或痛苦的事情。
All right. Well, let me ask you this. Say I have the ability to make you have amnesia. If I flip this switch, you won't remember your name. You won't remember who you are. What do you think?
好吧。嗯，我问你个问题。假如我有能力让你患上健忘症。如果我按下这个开关，你就记不住自己的名字了。你记不住你是谁。你觉得怎么样？
What do I think?
我怎么觉得？
Yeah, would you do it or not?
是啊，你会做还是不做？
Would you?
你会吗？
I would want to do it because then I think that I would lose my ego. I would lose this-- I would have a clean slate, sort of thing.
我想做，因为那样我觉得我会失去自我。我会失去这个——我会有一张白纸，那种感觉。
It would-- if all of a sudden you sat here and you couldn't remember why you're holding this microphone or who I am or why you're talking to me, to say it was disorienting would be too mild.
它会——如果你突然坐在这里，记不住你为什么要拿着这个麦克风，或者我是谁，或者为什么要和我说话，说这让人迷失方向都太轻了。
I think I would be smart enough to realize, this is a gift. I mean, there's two choices. Either you realize that it's a gift, or you completely freak out. One or the other.
我觉得我应该足够聪明，意识到这是一个礼物。我的意思是，有两个选择。要么你意识到这是一个礼物，要么你彻底崩溃。要么这样，要么那样。
You're talking as if you wake up in the morning, you don't know where you are, who you are, where in the hell you're going, and you're happy with it? Give me a [BLEEP] break.
你说的好像你早上醒来，不知道自己在哪里，不知道自己是谁，不知道自己该死地要去哪儿，你还很高兴？饶了我吧，[哔]的。
That still seems attractive to me. It still seems like it might be a good thing, to be put in a situation where I have to admit that I'm completely lost. It seems like--
那对我来说仍然很有吸引力。它看起来仍然可能是一件好事，被置于一种必须承认自己彻底迷失了的境地。这看起来好像——
Oh, I think you already are, Scott.
哦，我觉得你已经迷失了，斯科特。
After five days, having found no one who had, or had had amnesia, I decided to visit a hypnotherapist, Diane Bradshaw, and ask her if she could give me amnesia. She said she probably could do it, as long as I was willing to be put under hypnosis. She said some people just weren't willing.
五天后，没有找到一个患有或曾患健忘症的人，我决定拜访一位催眠治疗师黛安·布拉德肖（Diane Bradshaw），问她是否能让我健忘。她说只要我愿意接受催眠，她大概能做到。她说有些人就是不愿意。
And if you're open to the possibility that, say, amnesia would be OK for five minutes, or one minute, it might happen.
如果你对某种可能性持开放态度，比如健忘症持续五分钟或一分钟没关系，那它可能会发生。
Well, I'm open to  even a day, if that-- would that be a bad idea?
嗯，甚至持续一天我也持开放态度，如果那——那会是个坏主意吗？
What do you really want here? Do you want to get that extreme?
你到底想要什么？你想达到那种极端吗？
Well, let's say a few hours, anyway. Do you think-- what do you think? Because he's going to have to hang out with me.
嗯，哪怕几个小时吧。你觉得——你觉得怎么样？因为他得和我待在一起。
You know what I think?
你知道我是怎么想的吗？
I think an hour--
我觉得一个小时——
I think if you had a half-hour of amnesia, you would get it pretty quick.
我觉得如果你有半小时的健忘症，你很快就会明白的。
All right. An hour. Half-hour.
好吧。一个小时。半小时。
I think a half-hour would probably be plenty of time. And then I have to ask you, what do you want to forget? I mean, I can do anything from giving you a suggestion to forget your name, to forget where you live, to-- what do you want to forget?
我觉得半小时可能足够了。然后我得问你，你想忘记什么？我的意思是，我可以做任何事，从暗示你忘记你的名字，到忘记你住在哪里，到——你想要忘记什么？
Is it possible to forget everything? My whole self-identity? Is that too much?
有可能忘记一切吗？我整个自我身份？那是不是要求太多了？
Well, I--
嗯，我——
She took notes on what I wanted to forget. Then she hypnotized me, which involved having me count backwards from 100, and telling me to relax, deeper and deeper, and then having me imagine being in a big garden with a stream running through it. And she said, if I drank from the stream, I'd forget my name and where I was, and also the name of my friend who'd come with me. So I went and drank from the stream and she woke me up.
她在纸上记下了我想要忘记的事情。然后她催眠了我，让我从100倒数，告诉我放松，越来越深，然后让我想象自己身处一个有着溪流穿过的大花园里。她说，如果我喝了溪水，就会忘记自己的名字和身在何处，也会忘记和我一起来的那位朋友的名字。所以我就去喝了溪水，然后她把我唤醒了。
--five, open your eyes, all the way back, emerging from hypnosis. All the way back. Hi, there.
——五，睁开眼睛，完全回来，从催眠中出来。完全回来。你好。
Hi.
你好。
How are you doing?
你感觉怎么样？
Good.
很好。
Feels pretty good, doesn't it?
感觉不错，是吧？
It was pleasant.
很愉快。
Yeah.
是啊。
It was fun.
很有趣。
Yeah.
是啊。
But I think I can remember. I'm sorry.
但我好像能记起来。抱歉。
And what is it you can remember? What town do you live in?
你记得的是什么？你住在哪个城市？
Salt Lake. Sorry.
盐湖城。抱歉。
And what have you been doing today?
你今天都在做什么？
Uh. Working on this story.
呃。做这个故事。
Uh huh. And what's his name over here.
嗯哼。那在这儿的这位叫什么名字。
Trent Harris. I'm sorry, man. I tried. I did. I tried.
特伦特·哈里斯（Trent Harris）。抱歉，伙计。我试过了。真的。我试过了。
The next day, I typed "amnesia" into a search engine on the World Wide Web, and got a phone number for the Beckman Institute, a neuroscience center at the University of Illinois. I called up and talked to Rob Althoff, a graduate student, and he told me that the kind of amnesia I was looking for was, indeed, very rare, and that there's some disagreement over whether it even happens at all.
第二天，我在万维网的搜索引擎上输入“健忘症”，找到了伊利诺伊大学神经科学中心贝克曼研究所的电话号码。我打过去和研究生罗伯·奥尔托夫（Rob Althoff）谈了谈，他告诉我，我寻找的那种健忘症确实非常罕见，而且关于它是否真的存在还存在一些争议。
He said people do suffer long-term memory loss from severe brain injuries, but that usually these people never recover their memories, that the brain doesn't regenerate. And he said that the other kind of amnesia, where there's no physical trauma, is often a matter of the person not wanting to remember, for one psychological reason or another, and that in these cases it's really difficult to know whether the person is, basically, just faking it.
他说，人们确实会因严重的脑损伤而遭受长期记忆丧失，但这些人在大多数情况下永远无法恢复记忆，大脑不会再生。他还说，另一种没有身体创伤的健忘症，通常是当事人因为某种心理原因不想记忆，而在这些案例中，真的很难分辨当事人是否基本上是在装模作样。
Talking to Althoff made me wonder if amnesia, the kind we see on TV and in the movies, where a character gets hit on the head with a coconut, loses his self-identity, then spends the rest of the story rediscovering it or getting bonked on the head by another coconut-- whether this is really just a story that we want to be true. Everyone loves the idea of a second chance, of starting over without the burden of the past. I think that's why amnesia is in so many movies and TV shows and romance novels. We somehow want to believe in it.
和奥尔托夫的谈话让我怀疑，电视和电影里那种健忘症——角色被椰子砸了头，失去了自我，然后花掉剩下的时间重新发现自我，或者被另一个椰子砸头——是否真的只是一个我们希望成真的故事。每个人都喜欢“第二次机会”这个主意，那种不用背负过去重新开始的感觉。我认为这就是为什么健忘症出现在那么多电影、电视剧和爱情小说里的原因。我们不知为何就是想相信它。
[MUSIC -- "DON'T FORGET ME" BY MARIANNE FAITHFULL]
[音乐 -- 玛丽安娜·菲斯福尔的《别忘了我》]
Act Four, The Day Mom and Dad Fell in Love.
第四部分：妈妈和爸爸坠入爱河的那一天。
Do you know how Mom and I met?
你知道妈妈和我怎么认识的吗？
I think you were working an antelope story and Mom was doing filming or something. You met each other and then you liked each other. And then you married each other.
我想你当时在做一个羚羊故事，妈妈在拍摄什么东西。你们认识了，然后你们喜欢上了对方。然后你们结婚了。
I remember sitting on my front steps in the morning, waiting for her to ride up the hill on her bicycle. It was in the spring, late April, and it had been raining, steam coming up off the street and sidewalks. I was waiting on the steps and I realized that I was in love with her, and that everything was going to be different now. She'd ride up the hill and set her bike down on the grass. And we'd go inside, and she'd live with me there for a long time, maybe forever. I knew it. I saw the whole thing coming, just like I see everything now. The only thing missing is the ending.
我记得早上坐在家门口的台阶上，等着她骑自行车上山。那是春天，四月下旬，下过雨，街道和人行道上冒着蒸汽。我坐在台阶上等着，意识到我爱上了她，从现在起一切都要变了。她会骑车上山，把自行车放在草地上。然后我们进去，她会和我住在那里很长一段时间，也许永远。我知道。我预见了这一切，就像我现在预见一切一样。唯一缺少的是结尾。
I remember lots of times you were nice to mom. She told me once that for her birthday or for Christmas or something, you bought her perfume and you wanted to get her the right one. And so you went around and you had a sample of each, and you were smelling it. And you were deciding but you couldn't decide which one to give her. And then when you came home, you hugged her.
我记得很多次你对妈妈很好。她曾经告诉我，在她的生日或圣诞节还是什么节日，你给她买了香水，你想买对味道的。所以你到处去看，每种都试了试，你在决定但无法决定哪一种给她。然后当你回到家，你拥抱了她。
My house inside had no furniture, other than two chairs and a table. I made some coffee and moved the table over by the window so she could sit in the sun. She was a modern dancer, small and thin, wearing a white cotton blouse. No bra, no need for a bra, shorts and sandals and sweating a bit from the ride. Her skin was dark tanned already, so early. Lovely legs but with lots of scars on the knees and shins, and feet that were like little creatures unto themselves, beautiful and frightening. They had the structure of the Golden Gate Bridge, a high sinewy arch with built-in springs and pulleys and long toes stretching out for purchase.
我屋里没有家具，只有两把椅子和一张桌子。我泡了咖啡，把桌子移到窗边，这样她就可以坐在阳光下。她是现代舞者，娇小瘦弱，穿着白色棉衬衫。没戴胸罩，没必要戴，穿着短裤和凉鞋，因为骑车稍微出了一点汗。她的皮肤已经晒成了深褐色，这么早就晒得那么深。可爱的腿但膝盖和胫骨上有很多伤疤，脚就像一个个独立的小生物，美丽而令人惊恐。它们有着金门大桥的结构，高高的腱质足弓，带有内置的弹簧和滑轮，长脚趾伸展开来寻找着力点。
Do you feel like anything's a mystery between Hillary and me that you don't understand?
你觉得希拉里（Hillary）和我之间有什么你理解不了的谜团吗？
This week, when I ask our 11-year-old daughter Jessie this question. she pauses for at least a half a minute. I've asked maybe a million questions in my reporting career, but this has got to be the longest pause I've ever heard.
这周，当我问我们11岁的女儿杰西（Jessie）这个问题时，她停顿了至少半分钟。在我的报道生涯中，我可能问过一百万个问题，但这一定是我听过的最长的停顿。
I don't really think about it much. And I-- it's-- it's a hard thing to think about.
我没怎么细想过。而且我——这——这是一个很难想的问题。
Why?
为什么？
Because it's-- I usually don't pay much attention to what you and Mom are doing between each other. Well, kind of, I do. And I don't really wonder anything. I don't think that there's something that I don't know that I really want to know, like a mystery or anything.
因为这——我通常不怎么关注你和妈妈之间在做什么。嗯，有点，我会关注。我并没有真的好奇什么。我不觉得有什么我不知道但我非常想知道的事情，像什么谜团之类。
I'd seen her dance the night before in front of a small audience downtown, and her style was wrapped around the idea-- her idea-- that she really weighed nothing at all, and that her body was only there to tell little jokes-- her little jokes, whatever might come to mind.
前一天晚上我在市中心的小观众群前看过她跳舞，她的风格围绕着一个想法——她的想法——即她真的毫无重量，她的身体只是为了讲点小笑话——她的小笑话，无论想到什么。
I asked her if she liked my house, and she said she liked the view. She asked me what I thought about her concert, and I said I thought it was funny. She said, "Funny? Only funny?" "Funny and beautiful," I said. And she said, "That's better."
我问她喜不喜欢我的房子，她说她喜欢视野。她问我怎么看她的音乐会，我说我觉得挺有趣的。“有趣？只是有趣吗？”“有趣又美丽，”我说。她说，“那更好。”
Do you think Hillary and I are in love?
你觉得希拉里和我相爱吗？
Yeah. I mean, you-- I know because you sometimes have fights. I think people who love each other have to have fights sometimes. Otherwise they don't understand each other very well. Not everybody is exactly the same, and so people might disagree about something. But two people who love each other have to understand each other, and to understand each other, they have to know what they're thinking.
是啊。我的意思是，你——我知道是因为你们有时会吵架。我觉得相爱的人有时必须得吵架。否则他们就不能很好地理解彼此。每个人都不完全一样，所以人们可能会在某些事情上有分歧。但两个相爱的人必须理解彼此，而要理解彼此，他们必须知道对方在想什么。
Up until this time, I'd been living alone and was not unhappy. I had a house and a dog and a car, no job, no need for a job. I had money from the National Endowment for the Arts to produce a radio story about chasing antelope, which, as far as I could tell, only required a wholehearted effort to live as much like a primitive hunter as possible. It was a problem I was working on by myself, and really I had no idea how to go about it, other than by trying to live simply and by trying to stay outside and cover as much ground as possible. But there she was, finally arrived, come to stay.
在这之前，我一直独自生活，过得并不不开心。我有房子、狗和车，没有工作，也不需要工作。我有来自国家艺术基金会的钱去制作一个关于追逐羚羊的广播故事，据我所知，这只需要全身心地尽可能像原始猎人一样生活。这是一个我自己正在研究的问题，说实话我不知道该怎么做，除了试图简单生活，试图保持在户外并覆盖尽可能多的土地。但她就在那里，终于到了，决定留下来。
When you get married-- have you ever thought about getting married?
当你结婚时——你有没有想过结婚？
Not really. Not much.
没怎么想过。不太会。
Maybe a little bit?
也许有一点点？
I don't know. I mean, I don't believe we can ever guess the future or-- I can hope, but I don't like saying what I want to be when I grow up. Because you never know.
我不知道。我的意思是，我不相信我们能猜出未来或者——我可以希望，但我不喜欢说我长大后想成为什么样的人。因为你永远不知道。
She asked me why I only had one fork in the kitchen. I said it was all I needed, and then asked her how many she had in her kitchen. "Eight," she said, "and at least 10 spoons. And I have some glasses, different kinds, even wine glasses. I like to have friends over. I like to cook and have friends over to eat. Don't you have any friends?"
她问我为什么厨房里只有一把叉子。我说这是我所需要的，然后问她厨房里有几把。“八把，”她说，“至少10个勺子。而且我有一些杯子，各种各样的，甚至有葡萄酒杯。我喜欢邀请朋友来。我喜欢做饭，邀请朋友来吃。你没有朋友吗？”
"Yeah, I have a friend, but he doesn't have any hands," I said, looking over at my dog.
“是啊，我有个朋友，但他没有手，”我说，看着我的狗。
"You know," she said. "I've been dreaming about you. I think I'm in love with you."
“你知道吗，”她说。“我一直在做关于你的梦。我想我爱上你了。”
How do you know she supports me?
你怎么知道她支持我？
She doesn't wish-- I mean, she doesn't say it as that she regrets that she married you or that maybe not having a job sometimes. And so she still appreciates what she has.
她没有希望——我的意思是，她没有说她后悔嫁给你，或者有时没有工作。所以她仍然珍惜她所拥有的。
When you get married, if your marriage turns out like our marriage, between your mom and me, would that be good enough for you or would you want more than that?
当你结婚时，如果你的婚姻像我们的婚姻，你妈妈和我的婚姻那样，这对你来说足够好吗，还是你想要更多？
I think it would be fine. I mean, you guys seem pretty happy. And I think that if my marriage, if I got married, was like yours, I would be pretty happy too. And I think I would try to make a little more money. But otherwise, getting along like that, I think that would be a good marriage.
我觉得那挺好的。我的意思是，你们看起来挺幸福的。而且我认为如果我的婚姻，如果我结婚，像你们的一样，我也会非常幸福。而且我想我会试着多赚点钱。但除此之外，那样相处，我觉得那会是一场美满的婚姻。
Jessie Carrier was 11 when that story was recorded. It was a long time ago, though. She's going to be graduating from college in a couple weeks. Scott Carrier is working on a new book, Prisoner of Zion, and he's looking for a publisher for that. He's been teaching lately in the Communication department at Utah Valley University. The stories that you've heard this hour are collected in a book with some other stories. The book is called Running After Antelope. And you can hear Scott's very first radio story, the one that I talked about at the beginning of the program, with the people who he met while hitchhiking across the country, at transom.org.
杰西·卡里尔在录制那个故事时才11岁。不过那是很久以前的事了。她几周后就要大学毕业了。斯科特·卡里尔正在写一本新书《锡安的囚徒》（Prisoner of Zion），他正在找出版商。他最近一直在犹他河谷大学传播系任教。你这小时听到的这些故事收录在一本书里，还有其他一些故事。这本书叫《追逐羚羊》（Running After Antelope）。你可以在transom.org网站上听到斯科特的第一个广播故事，就是我在节目开头提到的那个，关于他在搭便车横跨全国时遇到的那些人。
All of the Scott Carrier stories in today's program were originally produced by at Alix Spiegel. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
今天节目中的所有斯科特·卡里尔故事最初由阿里克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）制作。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
And thanks to everybody who came out this past week to our live cinema event in 430 movie theaters across the country. In case you missed it, you get one more chance. There's going to be an encore presentation in movie theaters everywhere, Thursday, May 7. More information at our website, www.thisamericanlife.org.
感谢过去一周来到全国430家影院参加我们现场电影活动的所有人。如果你错过了，你还有最后一次机会。5月7日星期四，全国各地的影院将进行重映。更多信息请访问我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains his recent management decisions this way.
WBEZ电台对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他这样解释他最近的管理决定。
I was in a football game and two guys fell on my head.
我在踢足球，有两个人压在我头上。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。